[Music]
ladies and gentlemen a great show
tonight this is a little bit of a
bittersweet evening for us i'll tell you
why hard to believe i don't know it's
it's mind-boggling yeah yeah we're
coming up on 20 years on the air in uh
in a couple of months well i guess
somebody in about a year or so will be
20 years uh
in about 15 years we'll be 20 years old
we've been doing this for quite a while
well one of our writers good friends
he's a writer he's a performer brian
mccann
is uh leaving us he has been
working with me for 17
of those years 17 years and he's done an
incredible job and you know he's been a
huge part of this
absolutely journey to be incredibly
silly every night and i thought we
should take a second and highlight some
of his memorable characters
over the almost 20 years that he's been
here characters like preparation h
raymond yeah
there he is
uh
the guy with bulletproof legs one of my
favorite characters of all times
the guy with the kayak in the audience
the guy who's proud of his two-inch
penis
the guy who bowls whales
[Laughter]
s and m lincoln uh
yeah
robo hunk i love hunk yeah dave
yarborough the world's oldest stunt man
cloppy the horse
yeah clappy the horse
the 19th century douchebag
the robot on the toilet yeah
uh one of a newer one minty the candy
cane who briefly fell on the ground yeah
and ladies and gentlemen probably the
greatest character in the history of any
medium the fedex pope that's right
[Music]
that's so stupid
you know a lot of those characters
appeared on my old shows and for legal
reasons uh you know we can't show you
clips but i do encourage you to find
links to nearly 17 years of brian's work
at teamcoco.com
mccann let's bring him out here and say
farewell to a great man brian mccann
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll take a break when we come back
kieran cedric's here stick around
this is terrible
[Applause]
[Music]